it's hard to pick a favorite Tarantino
flick but the man himself has finally
settled on his own number one choice and
it may surprise some of the director's
biggest fans with three decades of
filmmaking under his belt Quentin
Tarantino is one of the foremost otors
of his generation his filmography is
full of rarely disputed Classics like
Pulp Fiction and Inglorious Bastards and
his material is known as merge for genre
bending as it is for his pension for
hyper violence and of course his
predilection for close-up shots of
people's feet his films have earned
Academy Awards and drawn reactionary
backlash in equal measure but what's
undeniable is that each one is a product
of a singular Vision a Tarantino movie
stands out in a lineup because their
movies no one else could have possibly
made Tarantino has always been vocal
about his opinions whether he's deriding
the MCU or ranking Star Trek over Star
Wars he's not afraid of rocking the boat
however when it comes to his own work
he's been reluctant to pick a favorite
movie from his catalog lately though
Tarantino has stepped away from the
camera and turned to the page he
published a novelization of his last
film 2019's Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood and now he's on a press tour
promoting his non-fiction volume Cinema
speculation recently Tarantino visited
the Howard Stern Show for a wide-ranging
interview during which he finally named
which of his films he likes best I
really do think once upon a time in
Hollywood is my best movie starring
Leonardo DiCaprio as actor Rick Dalton
and Brad Pitt as a stunt double Cliff
Booth once upon a time when Hollywood
opened in 2019 to mostly positive
critical reception set drawing the
Heyday of Hollywood during the late
1960s when westerns were in Vogue and
Bruce Lee was in his prime the movie has
been described as an Ode to a bygone era
of the film industry however the real
flourish on top of the proceedings comes
with Tarantino's decision to censor the
events of the film around the infamous
States La Bianca murders committed by
Charles Manson's followers Margot Robbie
takes them the role of Sharon Tate the
young Starlet murdered on that fateful
day in 1969 but in line with the
director's previous historical
revisionisms the movie climaxes with
Dalton and Booth who never existed in
real life inadvertently saving the day
Tarantino holds back on his usual
Tendencies toward graphic violence until
that linchpin scene then let's set a
rubbed and truly stunning fashion as a
Manson family members are taken out with
a dog fists and a flamethrower I love
that stuff you know they're killing a
lot of killing a lot of killing overall
it's a weird and Wild movie that doesn't
seem to care about audience
sensibilities and his brand did with
Tarantino's signature stylistic
flourishes from front to back it's easy
to see why the director would think it's
his best work it's clear that Tarantino
was given total leeway the plot meanders
through deviations and digressions
Cycles back on itself recursively and
because this is a Tarantino film the
camera fixed Saints on his star's feet
for uncomfortable amounts of time it is
in the truest sense a work of otor
filmmaking yes that means the movie is
uneven and sometimes flawed but that
lens of film its texture and personality
as Rolling Stones Peter Travers wrote in
his review you can feel Tarantino's mad
love for movies and all they're just
reputable Dazzle and subversive art in
every shot however other outlets such as
the guardian felt that once upon a time
in Hollywood seeded a bit too much
ground to Tarantino's personal fears and
Hang-Ups critic Wendy I'd noted that
some of the film's choices like Bruce
alleged History of Violence toward women
getting mentioned offhand feel like a
jab at the metoo movement while the
story of two performers on a career
decline could easily be read as
Tarantino's own fear of losing relevance
up to so much time in the sun still the
reviewer acknowledges that the movie is
clearly the product of a singular Vision
writing is a film that could only have
been made by one man ozma lee Once Upon
a Time in Hollywood might be the most
Tarantino movie yet and for the venerate
to the filmmaker himself thus an
achievement worth celebrating we're all
good don't need to go no we're done that
was fantastic
[Music]